wir werden uns heute mit zwei
philosophen befassen einmal mit dem der
letzten sitzung das war noch descartes
da hatten wir noch einige texte nicht
gelesen ich will jetzt nur die
wichtigsten texte noch nehmen die seine
methode betreffen und in der zweiten
hälfte werden wir dann uns befassen mit
leibniz und wollen da dann unter schauen
wie er den begriff der idee verwendet
welche theorie der wahrheit er verwendet
und wie sich seine theorie zu bereits
bekannten theorien die wir in diesem
seminar behandelt haben verhält so jetzt
müsste auch das bild bald kommen
hier ist er descartes wir lesen jetzt
noch ein paar auszüge aus seiner schrift
regula direktion im gdi das sind also
die regeln zur lenkung des verstandes
und ich habe ihn ja schon gesagt bei
deka findet sich ein gegenüber den
bereits behandelten theorien verändertes
verständnis von wahrheit es ist jetzt so
dass die karte nicht mehr wahrheit oder
tatsachen und objekte in der welt und
erkenntnis subjekt aufeinander bezieht
in einem art natürlichen verhältnis so
dass uns ihnen sich an augustinus dass
uns die dinge sogar täuschen können
das enge verhältnis wird aufgelöst durch
die modernen naturwissenschaften und es
steht jetzt eher die frage im zentrum
wie das objekt zur wahrheit gelangen
kann wie kommt es zu den dingen
es ist also nicht mehr von natur aus in
diesem kontext diese wahrheit kontext
sondern es kann getäuscht werden als ist
täuscht sich die dinge täuschen ist
natürlich nichts um es selbst hat dunkle
begriffe und es muss versuchen über
verschiedene apparaturen man kann sich
das fast schon naturwissenschaftlich
vorstellen aber bestimmte vorrichtungen
die es sich zur hilfe nimmt an die
wirklichkeit heran zu kommen man kann
sich das sehr guten analogie vorstellen
so mikroskopie zur entwicklung der
linsen schlage der linsen mikroskopie
also linsen schleifen die linse muss
geschliffen werden es muss die linse
muss miteinander anderen linse
kombiniert werden es muss eine gewisse
redaktion der der linsen geben damit
dann das objekt sagen wir was
mikroskopische mikroskopische objekt
damit dass dann möglichst scharf und
klar vorliegt und in dieser analogie
kann man sich eher descartes verhältnis
zur wahrheit durch ausdenken er kommt ja
aus einer zeit wo die modernen
naturwissenschaften sich sehr sehr
rasant entwickelt haben und wir lesen
jetzt einfach mal die texte nachdem wir
uns diese zwei leitfragen hier
vergegenwärtigt haben also wir hängt
wahrheit und methode beide karte
zusammen von methode ist kein wort bei
augustinus von methode ist kein wort bei
111 x thomas methode gibt es dort nicht
also wir hängen die zusammen ist
wahrheit überhaupt ohne methode zu
gewinnen und dann wenn man jetzt von der
methode ausgeht methode motors kritisch
heißt ja letztendlich weg also der weg
der zu einem ziel führt und dann kann
sich fragen welcher weg führt zur
wahrheit welche stationen sind auf
diesem weg zu nehmen sagt wenn sie jetzt
die folien die ich jetzt hier ein wand
werfe selbst auf dem endgerät sich
vorlegen wollen weil das vielleicht
nicht gut sichtbar ist können sie
einfach auf die seminare punkt net gehen
und sich die folien herunterladen die
sind da also abgelegt gut dann gehen wir
doch einfach mal hier nix ersten text
der von ihnen möchte mal lesen diesen
ersten text kann ist auch mal lesen das
ist jetzt so eine zusammenfassung seiner
methode wir hatten das letzte mal ja
schon ganz kurz die inbegriff der
natürlichen von des natürlichen lichts
dem griff des natürlichen lichts hatten
in der letzten sitzung mal kurz gehört
weiß jemand von ihnen noch was mitunter
diesem natürlichen licht zu verstehen
ist vielleicht eine kurze wiederholung
nach
er sagt das licht der natur das
natürliche licht auch nicht der vernunft
was kann das nach der cup meinen ist
natürlich eine metapher kann man sich
das vorstellen
das natürliche licht
hmm
ja genau also wir hatten gesagt bei
descartes findet sich eine
problematisierung des wahrheit'
verhältnisses immer im verhältnis von
halo ja sie dürfen nur nicht durchs bild
laufen weil ich oder wenn sie wollen
können sie durchs bild laufen aber seine
kamera ich weise darauf hin
also es ist so
dieses verhältnis von subjekt und objekt
wird bei descartes jetzt nicht völlig
losgelöst das subjekt ist nicht völlig
jenseits aller möglichen wahrheit sind
es besteht die möglichkeit dass es zur
tatsächlichen welt der sache wie sie
wirklich ist bezug aufnehmen kann
das ist allerdings problematisch oder
man könnte sagen es ist vermittelt nur
noch vermittelt möglich ist müssen da
zwischenschritte eingefügt werden
eingeführt werden ganz ähnlich wie man
zwischen das auge und das mikroskopische
objekt verschiedene linsen schaltet so
ungefähr muss man sich dieses diese
wahrheit theorie vorstellen es werden
bestimmte zwischenstationen eingeführt
eingefügt damit das erkennen des objekt
den zugang herstellen kann zur
wirklichkeit die wirklichkeit erschließt
sich nicht automatisch und dieses
natürliche licht wäre dann die
prinzipielle erkennbarkeit der
wirklichkeit die sich in bestimmten
momenten zeigt man kann natürlich noch
sagen natürliches licht ist evident
er hatte dass uns etwas einleuchtet wir
kommen auch noch auf evidenz zu sprechen
sie haben sich nicht gesehen bei
leibnitz 2000 längerer text mehr
leibnitz da wurde auch noch bezug
genommen auf die evidenz in einer stelle
als natürliches licht das heißt die welt
ist prinzipiell intelligenz kein
relatives gibt ja theoretiker späterer
provenienz ich würde auch nietzsche dazu
zählen auf den wir ja auch noch eingehen
die würden sagen wahrheit ist ein loses
konstrukt
es gibt natürlich auch noch relativ ist
nicht sagen wahrheit das heißt wahrheit
die welt wie sie wirkliches kameni
erkennen und die karte ist also keine
kein relativ ist in diesem sinne
aber er ist ein ein ich sage mal
vertritt eine kritische theorie der
wahrheit gesagt bevor wir die dinge
erkennen können müssen wir erst mal
schauen was wir überhaupt erkennen
können und wie wir erkennen sollen
und darin ist natürlich auch ein
vorläufer von kant immanuel kant auf
denen wir dann auch in der nächsten
sitzung zu sprechen kommen der sich auch
erste vor auf die wahrheit ab ziel frag
ja wie kann ich denn überhaupt erkennen
was sind die bedingungen der möglichkeit
von erkenntnis und von wahrheit als
diese wendung auf subjekt die ist hier
wichtig und noch dazu die vermittelte
suche nach der wahrheit also vom objekt
geht nichts aus das subjekt muss alles
tun um sich diesen objekt anzunehmen
durch geschickte vorrichtungen so jetzt
haben wir vor also die gesamte methode
besteht in der ordnung und gliederung
dessen worauf die schärfe des geistes zu
richten ist um eine wahrheit
herauszufinden
diese methode befolgen wir dann exakt
wenn wir verwickelte und dunkle pro
positionen stufenweise auf einfachere
zurückführen danach versuchen von der
intuition die allereinfachsten über
dieselbe stufen zur erkenntnis alle
anderen aufzusteigen
wie verstehen sie jetzt diese methode
ist eine gewisse bewegung drin auch wenn
sie jetzt mal schauen hier die rede von
aufsteigen wenn jetzt sieht das an
irgend eine theorie die wir schon hatten
nach dem höhengleichen genau
aufzusteigen abzusteigen
wie kann man sich das jetzt das
vorstellen wie kann man sich jetzt
vorstellen dass die verwickelten und
dunklen positionen stufe weisen auf
einfache zur einfachen zurückgeführt
werden kann man sich das vorstellen
könnte dass man andere worte fassen das
ist jetzt ja alles sehr abstrakt was
eine position ist wissen sie
genau
verlier ich denke man kann sich das auch
vorstellen unter komplexitätsreduktion
ist also ein eher reduktionistischen
ansatz oder ein analytischer als
vielleicht noch mit analytischer ansatz
also das zusammengesetzte das komplexe
was sich uns erst mal gar nicht
erschließt weil es uns vielleicht
überfordert in seinen zusammenhängen
nicht klar vor augen blickt das mal
zurückzuführen reduzieren oder zu
analysieren aufzulösen in seiner
einfachsten bestandteile und die
einfachsten bestandteile die müssen dann
intuitiv sein
die müssen uns dann ein leuchten die die
grundsätze dieses komplexen sach falls
man von diesen einfachen evidenten
grundsätzen müssen wir dann wieder
aufsteigen und zeigen wie das komplexe
aus ihn zusammen gebaut ist man könnte
es auch ganz einfach eine
rekonstruktionen eine rekonstruktion
wenn sich überlegen sie rekonstruieren
was sie verstehen erst dann eine sache
oder ein technisches gerät wenn sie es
rekonstruieren
sie verstehen jetzt zum beispiel diese
kamera die mich gerade filmt und
vielleicht nicht die ganze stunde film
wird weil der akku wieder aus ist diese
kamera verstehen sie dann im technischen
sinne nicht wenn sie sie zerlegen in
ihre einzelteile
verstehen sie gar nicht verstehen sie
nur wenn sie zerlegen und dann wieder
zusammenbauen und sie wissen wie die
teile in ihrem verhältnis sich
zueinander verhalten
das ist als rekonstruktion und das ist
doch mal was ganz neues jetzt im
vergleich zu den theorien bei
aristoteles platon haben wir sowas mit
dieser da ist es allerdings anders da
steigen wir erst auf und dann wieder
herab aber dieses herabsteigen hat es so
ein bisschen was davon diese bewegung
man könnte hier das höhlengleichnis
damit in verbindung bringen aber es ist
doch was ganz anderes
ein ganz anderes ein fast schon
technisches verständnis der
wahrheitsfindung und genauso übrigens
auch mit der rekonstruktion ist es auch
wenn sie philosophische hausarbeiten
schreiben kann ich einen kurzen exkurs
einfließen lassen wir reden auch mal
oder wenn sie jetzt eine schriftliche
leistung finden
seminar erbringen wir reden in der
nächsten sitzung vielleicht mal zu
beginn kurz darüber weil sie sicherlich
vielleicht auch schon ein oder andere
thema sich überlegt haben worüber sie
gerne schreiben würden auch da ist es so
dass sie wenn sie argumentieren oder
über ein text reden philosophisch dass
sie die nicht nur analysieren sollen
sind dass sie ihn rekonstruieren soll im
idealfall das ist natürlich eine hohe
kunst auch da ist es somit texten mit
gedanken das genauso da haben wir auch
eine wenn sie den text haben auch dieser
text selbst den wir gerade selbst hier
vor uns haben ist eine komplexe
proposition könnte man sagen
dieser text vor allem bei leibnitz der
wahlweise der war sehr sehr kompliziert
ich weiß dass ich sie da vielleicht ein
bisschen überfordert habe heute mit der
heutigen sitzung denn das ist auch
nichts anders als eine komplexe
proposition und was sie eine hausarbeit
oder in einer schriftlichen leistungen
für die so viel machen sollten
idealerweise ist diesen text erst mal zu
analysieren zurückzuführen auf seine
prämissen oder geringeren bestandteile
und dann von diesen bestandteilen
ausgehend zu zeigen wie man wieder
dorthin kommt wo sich der text und zeigt
als ihn nicht nur zu analysieren sondern
in gewisser weise nachzubauen
auch das ist die rekonstruktion in der
philosophie wichtig ist erst wenn sie
das ganze nach bauen auf basis der
einfachen teile haben sie es verstanden
und sie haben es nicht verstanden wenn
sie es nur reduzieren sie müssen schauen
wie hängt die einfachsten momente die
einfachsten teile miteinander zusammen
und diese rekonstruktion zeigt gerade
dass sie auch unabhängig vom wortlaut
eines textes von dem jahrgang oder was
auch immer von der technologie mit
eigenen worten diesen sachverhalt
darstellen können wenn sie das mit
eigenen worten machen können dann wissen
sie so ganz verstanden sind nicht mehr
abhängig von einem duktus des textes
sind nicht mehr gebunden daran sondern
sie können das ganze aus einer anderen
perspektive beleuchten
sie sind viel flexibler im umgang mit
diesem thema also soviel dazu
rekonstruktion ist überall wichtig um zu
verstehen
genau das ist diese diese methode und
jetzt geht er hier ein bisschen genauer
darauf ein er verwendet auffälliger
weise immer
wie der metaphern vergleiche ich lese
auch mal vor in diesen einen ist der
kern aller menschlichen aktivität
enthalten und wer die erkenntnis der
dinge in angriff nehmen möchte sollte
diese regel die wir vorhin vorgestellt
haben genauso wir folgen dir jemand der
ein labyrinth betreten wir den faden des
theseus folgt sie wissen was der faden
das tier soll es ist kann es jemand von
ihnen sagen für die anderen konditionen
oder weiß jemand nicht der faden des
theseus ja wollen sie mal erklären ja
ach sie wissen sich gut ja wir möchten
wir erklären unsere kommilitonen und
kommilitoninnen bitte
diese ariadne faden der rote faden das
ist auch eine metapher häufige metaphern
minotaurus sind alles so monster house
ist der stier sind alles zu mischwesen
an vielen dank und genau wie man in
einem labyrinth sich orientiert muss man
methodisch vorgehen die ariane war sehr
methodisch sie hat also sich da über die
methode zur wahrheit gedanken gemacht
sie ist nicht blind hat nicht blind
ratschläge erteilt und ähnlich ist es
hier brauchen einen roten faden der rote
faden zur wahrheit letztendlich den
faden des tesa ist folgt viele leute
aber denken entweder gar nicht über das
nach was sie vorschreibt die methode
oder es ist ihnen schlicht unbekannt
oder sie tun so als hätten sie es nicht
nötig unterziehen schwierigste fragen
oft so ungeordnet eine prüfung dass es
fast den anschein hat sie würden
versuchen mit einem sprung vom untersten
stockwerk eines gebäudes zum obersten zu
gelangen weil sie die treppenstufen doch
eigentlich dafür da sind dass es wieder
die methode die schritte eigentlich da
sind entweder geflissentlich übersehen
oder sie gar nicht bemerkt haben
sie machen es so machen es alle
astrologen sie geben sich der hoffnung
hin die wirkungen der himmelsregion
angeben zu können ohne ihre natur
erkannt oder sogar ohne ihre bewegungen
vollkommen beobachtet zu haben
ebenso auch die meisten die mechanik
ohne physik studieren und aufs
geratewohl neue geräte zur erzeugung von
bewegung herstellen und nicht weniger
auch jene philosophen die experimente
unterlassen und meinen die wahrheit
werde aus ihrem eigenen gehirn
entspringen die minerva aus dem
jupiters das ist ja sehr anschaulich
können sie nochmal die kritik hier mit
eigenen worten formulieren
rekonstruieren was die kritik ist die e
card hier an methodischen wahrheit'
zugängen weiß versuchen äußert sie
könnte man es auf den begriff bringen
was ist die kritik sind begriff gemacht
ja
[Musik]
genau das ist ein punkt also man könnte
sagen dass wahrheit' verständnis wird an
die autonomie des subjekts
zurückgebunden als das subjekt muss sich
selbst bestimmen in seiner
wahrheitssuche die wahrheit kriegen wir
nicht frei haus das hat mir aber auch
schon bei platon wahrheit ist etwas
anstrengendes wenn sie nochmal sich
überlegen wie er diese gefangenen
darstellt die gegen ihren willen
tranchen gezwungen werden sich diesem
sehr grellen licht zuzuwenden das ist
unangenehm da haben eine gewisse nähe zu
platon aber hierbei die karten noch
deutlicher wir müssen uns selbst
bestimmen und wir müssen uns selbst
bestimmen
zur wahrheit zu sagen wir zwei meldungen
ist hier und dann zieht aber erst ganz
hinten genau sie also vorletzte reihe
machen ich natürlich
guter punkt genau also das denken selbst
wird zum experiment und was auch wichtig
ist die wahrheit zeigt sich nicht
unmittelbar die wahrheit gibt sich frei
haus
die wahrheit wird uns nicht einfach so
dahin gestellt sondern die wahrheit kann
nur über schritte über vermittlung
stationen ein prozess eine methode
erreicht werden also wahrheit ist nicht
unmittelbar vorhanden
wir sind vielleicht wenn sie wieder sie
erinnern an diese letzte sitzung da wir
sind einem setting also wieder diese
rahmenbedingung müssen andere
rahmenbedingungen befinden uns nach
descartes wo wahrheit prinzipiell
möglich ist wo die tatsachen eingesehen
werden können aber das verhältnis von
subjekt und zu erkennen der wahrheit ist
mit hindernissen verstellt die
gewissermaßen auch weg geräumt werden
müssen ja da ist auch eine meldung
jahre alt
wichtig mit diesem angeborenen ideen ist
ein guter punkt diese nation ist in
athen kommen auch bei leibnitz noch
drauf die frage ist welchen status haben
diese ideen
es gibt natürlich und descartes wird ja
häufig den rationalisten zugezählt als
er ist kein app er ist würde sicherlich
wenn sich noch mal erinnern an die
meditation wir sind ganz kurz darauf
eingegangen
descartes sagt ich muss das sicherste
finden das prinzip was an aller
sichersten ist und da müssen muss ich
erstmal meine sinne ausschalten
also meines meinen sinn muss erstmal
misstrauen methodisch mythologisch
erstmal glauben die sinne würde mich
täuschen als descartes hat sicherlich
einen ganz großen schwerpunkt auf diesen
logischen ideen also setzte setzte vom
aus der sitzung ausgeschlossenen dritten
wir kommen auch theologische prinzipien
die uns unmittelbar einleuchtend das ist
natürlich auch eine möglichkeit am 2 zu
gelangen nur müssen wir auf die ja auch
erst kommen also wir haben sie in uns
wir haben gewisse logische prinzipien
die uns einleuchten
aber wenn wir von komplexen
sachverhalten ausgehen wie sie hat sich
uns meistens stellen dann müssen wir
verschiedene schritte hinter uns bringen
wir kommen dann am ende auf elemente
gewissermaßen die uns ein leuchten aber
eben nicht unmittelbar das ist glaube
ich das entscheidend also diese die
wahrheit zeigt sich uns nicht
unmittelbar
wir müssen sie erst erreichen über eine
mythologische reflexion ist auch ganz
interessant hier gilt zb regel wird das
kritisieren regel wird sagen ein
instrumentalist ische erkenntnistheorie
das kann man auch eine instrumentalist
ische erkenntnistheorie nennen also das
erkenntnis nur durch vor schaltung eines
instruments möglich ist wie sie jetzt
sich das vorstellen können dass sie also
ein mikroskop zwischen ihr auge und das
objekt setzen wie gesagt ein
instrumentalist ische erkenntnistheorie
ist von vornherein verfehlen diese
vornherein verfehlt das instrument
trägt gar nichts dass unsere wahrheit
bei ist macht die sache sogar noch viel
schlimmer das ist ein völlig falsches
eine völlig falsche vorstellung des
settings würde hegel sagen wie überhaupt
erkennen können wie genau regelt diese
kritik äußert werden wir noch sehen will
nur sagen eine solche auffassung von
wahrheitsfindung die auch kant vertritt
letztendlich dass wir bevor wir erkennen
uns erst mal gedanken machen müssen über
unsere erkenntnisfähigkeit die ist nicht
unwidersprochen geblieben
wollen sie mal kurz vorlesen verdienten
genauso vielen dank also da kommen wir
jetzt auch noch drauf haben wir wieder
dieses licht das licht der vernunft oder
vielleicht auch nicht die natur also die
prinzipielle erkennbarkeit der welt die
sich uns durch evidenz zeigt aber eben
nicht bei komplexen positionen nicht
unmittelbar wir lesen einfach nur weiter
und jetzt ist also die frage wie wir
genau zu dieser wahrheit kommen ich lese
vor um die die allereinfachsten dinge
von den verwickelten zu unterscheiden
und geordnet zu verfolgen müssen wir bei
jeder serie von dingen der wir einige
wahrheiten direkt auseinander
deplatziert haben beobachten was das
einfachste ist und wie weit mehr oder
weniger oder gleich alles übrige von ihm
entfernt ist
obwohl diese vorschrift nichts wirklich
neues zu mehren scheint so enthält sie
denn auch das tiefste geheimnis der
technik ganz wichtig spricht von einer
technik eine war heiztechnik es gibt in
diesem gesamten traktat keine nützlichen
sie weist nämlich darauf hin dass sich
alle dinge in bestimmte serien anlegen
lassen und zwar nicht in sofern sie auf
irgendeine gattung des seinen
zurückgeführt werden sowie die
philosophen sind ihre kategorien
eingeteilt haben
also insofern sie auseinander erkannt
werden können wir können deshalb immer
sofort wenn irgend eine schwierigkeit
auftritt feststellen ob es angebracht
sein wird vorher andere einige andere
dinge durchzugehen und zwar welche
ebenso wie in welcher ordnung und das
nun aber richtig tun zu können muss
zuerst darauf hingewiesen werden dass
alle dinge in dem sinne dem sie für
unser vorhaben nützlich sein können
entweder absolut oder relativ genannt
werden können wobei wir nicht ihre
isolierten naturen betrachten sondern
sie miteinander vergleichen um sie
auseinander erkennen zu können
wie verstehen sie jetzt das was er sagt
über diese serie von dingen
hier oben
hier dass ich alle dinge in bestimmte
serien anlegen lassen
hmm
so genau und nicht
und hier unten sagt aber nicht wobei wir
nicht ihre isolierten naturen betrachten
sondern sie miteinander vergleichen um
sie auseinander erkennen zu können
ob das ein guter punkt den verhältnissen
zu denken auch das hat auch dieses
dieses momentes rekonstruieren
wir erleben nicht nur sondern wir bauen
wieder auf und dem wir aufbauen müssen
wir sie immer vom anderen her versuchen
zu verstehen es muss ich gewissermaßen
gegenseitig ja spiegeln oder anders
gesagt denken sie wird man die wahrheit'
verständnisse die wir bisher hatten ja
was von der theorie von wahrheit scheint
denn dem jetzt zu grunde zu legen wenn
es um diese rekonstruktion geht in den
verhältnissen
genau das scheint mir auch
also ich vielleicht jetzt nicht als
natürlich jetzt nicht in allerletzte
hinsicht streng genommen vielleicht
nicht er spricht hier nie von korinth
aber wie sie richtig sagen glaube ich
die gedanken der rekonstruktion scheint
auch wenn jetzt hier die rede von
auseinander ist scheint auch so eine
abstimmung zu erfordern die sachen
müssen in sich stimmig sein
das hatten sie sich aber noch gemeldet
ja
auch
roman
guter hinweis ja also sie haben jetzt
verschiedene begriffe noch eingeführt
die wir vielleicht auch für die anderen
teilnehmer klären müssen also aktion
das sind dann die obersten gewissen
prinzipien die uns unmittelbar
einleuchtend setzte die uns gewiss sind
haben sie hatte man beispiel von aktion
was wäre so eine aktion typischer fall
eines möglichen aktion aktion kommt aus
dem griechischen araxos und aktions
heißt wert würdig sind also würdige
setzte also die wertvollsten setzte
sozusagen genau wie wie lautet der genau
leibnitz bringt dann noch so dieser
leibnitz text war ja sehr gehaltvoll
ich wollte sie auch also wirklich
methodologische also wollte sie
methodisch überfordern kann also nicht
dass ich denke ich bin jetzt hier
gemeinsam hat alles methode bei mir
wir wollen jetzt soweit kommt und bleibt
nichts bringt zb auch sowas wenn man
gleiches zu gleichem addiert dann kommt
gleiches raus erhalten wir gleich ist
oder wenn wir gleiches vergleichen
wegnehmen dann kommt gleich es raus
erhalten gleiches könnte auch ein
aktions seien einfach einfach so ein
prinzip und allgemeiner satz der
unmittelbar einleuchtend ist auf dem
aber anderes passiert und mit dem man
dann wie der kommilitone gesagt hat du
zieren kann man ableiten aus prämissen
von aktionen kann man konkreteres sachen
dann ab bleiben oder sie wieder darauf
zurückführen
gut ja also völlig richtig also ist es
dreht sich hier deswegen bin ich auch
noch nicht ganz sicher was ist jetzt ist
ist es der andere kollegen hat völlig zu
recht gesagt ist muss aber doch auch
hier so ein moment der korrespondenz
geben
aber natürlich diese rekonstruktion die
im subjekt in dieser technik das kann
man auch wirklich sich hier
unterstreichen hier diese technik
technik der wahrheit eine wahrheits
technik könnte man sagen eine kunst eine
wahrheits kunst die kunst die wahrheit
zu finden
die kunst die wahrheit zu rekonstruieren
zu produzieren vielleicht ist eine sache
des objekts und wir wir haben in dieser
technik sehr viele verfahren die da eine
rolle spielen die wir unter den begriff
einer karenz theorie bringen können also
und dann stellt sich aber im letzten
schritt wie sie richtig sagen die frage
hier aber wenn ich jetzt noch soviel
konstruiere konstruiert habe wo wann
habe ich dann die korrespondenz ich kann
noch soviel die duh ziehen
rekonstruieren zusammenbauen und wann
habe ich die korrespondenz und haben sie
eine idee wann die karts sagen würde
dass die korrespondenz eintritt was dann
bei descartes sich einstellt wenn die
die kurven zu korrespondenz führt was
dann greift bei der karte das ist jetzt
auch mal so eine erst mal eine these die
ich nur so wage jetzt mal ins spiel
bringe ich glaube dass das dann die
evidenz ist ich glaube das licht der
vernunft das natürliche licht ist dann
das wenige was anzeigt dass die kohärenz
zu korrespondenz geworden ist da findet
die über eine übereinstimmung zeigt sich
wer jetzt an meine these wir können
darüber diskutieren an der evidenz an
diesem licht was uns aufgeht
ja
ja also wichtig also es ist es hat es
hat wirklich etwas davon damit zu tun
dass es erst im subjekt bleibt und wir
müssen uns wirklich fragen wie sie
zurecht gesagt haben wie wir dann von
diesem subjekt letztendlich zu den
tatsachen kommen können es ist doch was
anderes und der kommilitone hat zu recht
darauf hingewiesen dass das eine gewisse
ähnlichkeit zu kant hat erkannt da
kommen wir noch drauf kann sagt wir
können nur erkennen bevor wir die
bedingung der möglichkeit der erkenntnis
geklärt haben bevor wir unser erkenntnis
apparat unser erkenntnisvermögen
kritisch geprüft haben kritisiert haben
kann deswegen heißt kannst du auch an
die kritische theorie kritisch heißt
jetzt nicht in dem sinn dass es
problematisch ist oder dass es irgendwie
eine schlechte oder sonstige gefährliche
erkenntnistheorie ist sein ganz einfach
im einfachsten silber könnte das auch
wieder hier auf die karts begriff der
technik zurück beziehen
kritischer philosophie heißt einfach nur
eine philosophie die sich mit den
bedingungen der möglichkeit von
erkenntnis auseinandersetzt die also
unsere erkenntnis leistung erst mal
prüft analysiert bevor sie überhaupt von
wahrheit spricht bevor sie überhaupt
erkennt natürlich kann man jetzt sagen
aber die prüfung unseres erkenntnis
vermögens ist auch wieder eine
erkenntnis also führt das nicht in
unendlichen regress ja also wir sagen
bevor wir erkennen können müssen wir
unsere erkenntnisvermögen prüfen aber
auch die erkenntnis vermögen müssen ja
dann erkannt werden und so weiter und
sofort kommen ja immer ein weiterer
kreis rhein das hat ja gar kein ende die
können wir denn unsere
erkenntnisvermögen überhaupt erkennen
müssen wir unsere vermögen zum erkennen
der erkenntnisvermögen wieder prüfen und
das dann wieder weiterhin zum
unendlichen regress deshalb kegel regel
sagt so ein versuch einer
instrumentalist ischen technischen
erkenntnistheorie ist von vornherein
verfehlt das ganze setting ist falsch
sagt ekel
ich wollte also nur darauf hinweisen es
gibt probleme einer solchen auffassung
von wahrheit weil nämlich wie der andere
kommilitonen gesagt hat wir tendenziell
worauf hingewiesen hat wir tendenziell
immer in diesem subjekt bleiben die
frage ist wie kommen wir aus diesem
subjektiven kohärenten strukturen die
wie sie richtig sagen sprachlich
verfassten sprachlich logisch induktiv
vorhanden sind wie kommen wir dann zu so
was wieder übereinstimmen
richtig also wir haben wirklich ein
problem das wir selbst ein bisschen
meine these wieder ein bisschen sehr
plakativ jetzt dass wir von diesem
korrespondenz modell wegkommen so ein
subjektives tischen karenz modell und
das dann korrespondenz im sinne eines
effekts der licht der vernunft
beschrieben wird der sich in der evidenz
manifestiert
ja
gut sehr gut und es gibt auch bei platon
in den späteren werken noch eine noch
passagen wo er sagt die ideen erkenntnis
hat nichts mehr von dieser mystische
schau dass uns die idee jetzt
aufleuchtet und wieso bezug zu den
verein wesenheiten nehmen und dann die
schwachen abbilder in der wirklichkeit
erkennen sondern er sagt es gibt eine
methode und das ist die dialektik die
elektrische methode das ist letztendlich
eine form der begriffs analyse und die
betriebsanalyse hat auch sowas detektive
es geht in diese richtung von descartes
aber wenn sie sich das setting nochmal
anschauen
dieses dreieck von platon was wir da
häufiger schon hier an gezeichnet hatten
was sie auf dem seminar punkt nicht
finden
dieses dreieck ist doch ein anderes
setting weil das objekt keine so große
rolle spielt das objekt ist immer schon
in der wahrheit drin könnte man sagen es
hat die wahrheit nur vergessen es ist ja
diese ponte plattform
wir wissen alle was die dinge sind wir
haben die wesen heiden alle mal geschaut
wir haben sie nur vergessen und müssen
es wieder daran erinnern gut dann kann
man sagen aber beide card haben wir doch
auch diese logischen grundbegriffe die
ideen die logischen bestandteile die uns
unmittelbar ein leuchten und die nur
verdunkelt sind ne müssen wir uns da
nicht auch eigentlich nur noch daran
erinnern an diese einfachsten
bestandteile kann wieder sagen ist ganz
ähnlich nun aber ich denke doch dass das
setting ein anderes ist weil einfach
diese technische vorrichtung diese
methodologische annäherung dieses
rekonstruktive bemühen dass das sogar
plattform nicht gegeben ist aber könnte
es könnte versuchen noch mehrere nähen
herzustellen also wir müssen uns da
jetzt gar nicht definitiv da irgendwie
einig werden es ist nur wichtig dass
immer sehen wie verhält sich zu platt
von wie verhält sich zu arbeiten lässt
wo sind die nähen die die unterschiede
das ist immer ganz hilfreich und ich
glaube doch dass wir jetzt eine starke
betonung der kohärenz haben wobei
descartes glaubt dass die kohärenz
tatsächlich auch die wahrheit verkündet
als die corinths eben auch die
korrespondenz irgendwie impliziert wie
auch immer wir müssen uns noch genauer
betrachten jetzt hatten wir hier die
rede davon dass es alle dinge in dem
sinne also dass sie absolut oder relativ
genannt werden können
und jetzt müssen wir schauen jetzt geht
es als logische wie der chronischen
sagte jetzt wird das ganze sprachlich
logisch aufbereitet zubereitet und jetzt
müssen wir schauen wie die kattas genau
macht absolut nenne ich das was sie rein
und einfacher natur dessen in sich
enthält worauf sich die frage gerichtet
wie all das was als gleichsam unabhängig
als ursache einfach allgemein eines
gleich ähnlich gerade oder anderes der
gleich betrachtet werden kann
genau dieses erste wenn ich auch das
einfachste und leichteste dass sich
verwenden lässt um fragen zu lösen
das ist das absolute wir müssen nochmal
weiter lesen was jetzt das relative ist
und das genauer zu verstehen relativ
dagegen ist das was zwar eigentlich
genau dieselbe natur hat wie das
absolute oder zumindest an etwas von
dessen natur teil hat also nicht so dass
das absolut jetzt über allem schwebt
irgendwie eine andere sphäre ist das
label selbst setting und das demgemäß
auf es zurückgeführt und ausgehend von
ihm über eine bestimmte serie d doziert
werden kann also jetzt wissen wir dass
serien sind sehen sind logische ab
leitungs verhältnis sehe sind logische
schritt
methodische schritte doch enthält es
darüber hinaus in seinem griff noch eine
bestimmte andere natur die
ichbezogenheit nenne
hierzu gehört alles was man abhängig
wirkung zusammengesetzt besonders vieles
ungleich unähnlich ungerade und so
weiter nennt ein relatives ist umso
weiter von dem absolut entfernt je mehr
derartige einander untergeordnete
bezogenheit es enthält diese regel
weisen uns an alle diese bezogen heiten
von einer
zu unterscheiden und ihre wechselseitige
verpflichtung und natürliche ordnung so
einzuhalten dass er vom letzten bis zu
dem das in höchst möglichen gerade
absolut iss gelangen können nehmen wir
durch alle anderen hindurchgehen
das hat doch jetzt auch ein bisschen was
platonische schon wieder diese aufstiegs
bewegung hin zu den absoluten bei es
jetzt bei descartes eben nicht unter
logisch gedacht wird das absolute ist
nicht unlogisch irgendwie rüber
schwebendes wie plakativ gesagt ideen es
geht es geht um eine logische reichen
sie müssen zu den aktionen aufsteigen
wir müssen das rekonstruieren endlich
hmm
genau
genau genau als sie sprechen wichtigen
punkt an
das scheint mir auch dieses momentes
sein was die korrespondenz ermöglicht
diese natürliche ordnung wie die sachen
wirklich ist die natur ist die sache so
wie sie da tatsächlich ist die
natürliche ordnung genauso auch wenn sie
noch mal ändern die metapher das
natürliche licht ja ja das natürliche
licht verbirgt die korrespondenz wenn
wir von natur reden haben wir die welt
so wie sie eigentlich ist
ja also richtig also es gibt besondere
form von urteilen und es gibt
analytische urteile das sind also
tautologie zum beispiel alle
junggesellen sind unverheiratet
analytischer satz der unternehmen wir
nur eine betriebsanalyse also
unverheiratet ist analytisch ist
enthalten im begriff des junggesellen
der junggeselle der verheiratet wäre
wäre ein begrifflicher widerspruch und
es gibt synthetische urteile wo das
prädikat nicht im subjekt enthalten ist
die sonne geht morgen auf menschen
werden im durchschnitt 80 jahre 85 oder
der satz wie auch immer also eben setzte
die gehalts erweitern sind ja die wo das
prädikat objekt enthalten ist
es steht nicht steht nicht im begriff
der sonne das jeden morgen aufgeht sie
wird irgendwann nicht existieren
bieber kann sich darüber streiten aber
es ist was anderes
und ich glaube dass diese satzverhältnis
hierbei descartes schon angelegt sind
aber natürlich steht dazwischen noch
leibnitz diese unterscheidung von
analytischen und synthetischen urteilen
die finden wir erst bei leibnitz und
dann greift sie auch noch kant auf ja
also es geht darum dass wir zeigen wie
sich unser denken das sprachlich logisch
er verfasst ist wie dieses denken wenn
es sich in eine ordnung bringt wie es
dann wirklichkeit oder wahrheit
generieren werden kann
und ich glaube die natürliche ordnung
ist hier ein guter hinweis darauf dass
es um eine korrespondenz letztendlich
geht die aber und das ist ein problem
was sie durchaus dich auch mal von hause
weitere legen können oder fern beitrag
als überlegen können wie kommen wir
beide card nach allen logischen
rekonstruktionen dann doch noch zur
wirklichkeit was zur bild
diesen bezug von denken und sein
wasserburg den oder schleicht sich da
nicht noch eine prämisse eine annahme
mit ein die wm gar nicht schenken müssen
ja was leistet letztendlich sind
übergangen ja
mit determination ich denke card geht
davon aus dass alles determiniert ist
das ist auch so eine prämisse bei ihm
weil nur das was determiniert ist sich
ja mit gründen erkennen lässt also die
karte hätte große schwierigkeiten mit
phänomenen wie wir sie jetzt in der
quantenphysik kennen die jetzt uns
jedenfalls als im determiniert
erscheinen also descartes setzt voraus
letztendlich das ist auch wieder das
setting sein setting ist deterministisch
alles hat einen grund eine ursache alles
und deswegen ist es auch erkennbar das
ist auch so diese diese annahmen weil
alles kausal determiniert ist
prädestiniert ist im können jetzt
erkennen
eine spannende frage ist dann wie sich
diese prinzipielle detailliertheit mit
gründen zur menschlichen freiheit
verhält beide partner das ist ein
anderes thema die karte ist ein
vertreter der willensfreiheit hat als im
starken freiheitsbegriff und das ist
dann spannend wie das dann zusammen
passt diese sehr starke nationalistische
determinismus wie sich der mit seiner
theorie von willensfreiheit verhält noch
spannender wird diese frage bei leibnitz
zwei leibnitz ähnlich wie descartes man
verspricht ein rationalist ist und
bleibt immer sagt alles hat mit dem satz
von zureichenden grunde zu tun
alles hat allen grund alles hat eine
ursache alles und wenn alles eine
ursache hat dann muss man sich fragen ob
da überhaupt noch so etwas wie ein
freier wille sein ort hat und leibnitz
hat eine ganz interessante theorie
entwickelt und zu zeigen dass trotz der
rede termination alle dessen was
existiert wird dennoch einen freien
willen annehmen können aber es ist das
ist ein riesenthema
aber beide card kann man schon sagen das
setting ist und deterministische alles
hat seinen grund alles lässt sich aber
auch wegen dieser gründe erkennen
prinzipiell
ja
genau der punkt genau
ja also es geht letztendlich descartes
darum eine logische ein logisches oder
ein subjektives experiment zu machen
er überträgt diese
naturwissenschaftliche methode auf die
logik oder auf unser verfasstheit des
denkens so müsste man zwar logik ist
vielleicht zu eng gefasst auf die
subjektivität auf die leistung der
subjektivität also dass das anwendungs
objekt ist nicht mehr die natur auf die
jetzt die methode angewendet wird sind
die subjektivität die logik die sprache
des denkens ein experiment des denkens
könnte man sagen
während eben die naturwissenschaften die
natur befragen die methode auf die natur
richten
descartes die methode auf unser denken
was nicht heißt dass er nicht auch
empirische fakten einbeziehen kann aber
die naturwissenschaft sind logische
axiome nicht dermaßen von bedeutung wie
für die karten dass die naturgesetze für
die naturwissenschaften die naturgesetze
dass die aktion wir müssen die
naturgesetze herausfinden wir müssen
wissen wie jetzt die gravitationskraft
ist warum sich dinge im freien fall
beschleunigen warum die geschwindigkeit
anstalt ja das hat das hat jetzt mit
logischen aktion unmittelbar nichts mehr
zu tun also dass eine gewisse analogie
ja dann können wir mal vielleicht
weiterlesen
und jetzt kommt wieder die technik das
geheimnis der gesamten technik besteht
darin war alledem bei allem auf das im
höchsten grade absolute zu achten
einiges ist zwar unter dem ein
gesichtspunkt in höheren gerade absolut
als anderes anderes betrachtet anders
betrachtet aber ist es in höheren gerade
relativ so ist zwar das allgemeinen
hören gerade absolut als das besondere
weil es eine in höheren gerade einfache
natur hat aber es kann in höherem maße
relativ genannt werden weil es von
individuen abhängt um zu existieren usw
ebenso sind zuweilen bestimmte dinge
wirklich gehören gerade absolut als an
obgleich sie keineswegs schon die in
höchstem grade absoluten von allen sind
so ist zb eine art etwas absolutes wenn
wir auf die individuen individuum
blicken habe etwas relatives wenn wir
auf die gattung blicken
unter den messbaren ist die ausdehnung
etwas absolutes unter den ausgibt
ausdehnung aber die länge und so weiter
außerdem haben wir mit absicht ebenso
die ursache und das gleiche zum
absoluten gezählt nämlich damit wir
besser ein sind dass wir die serie der
zu erkennen dinge und nicht die natur
jedes einzelnen dinge betrachten
obwohl ihre natur wirklich relativ ist
denn bei den philosophen sind ursache
und wirkung zwar relativ aber hier
fragen wir danach wie die wirkung
beschaffen ist und dabei ist es nötig
zuerst die ursache zu erkennen und nicht
umgekehrt gleiche dinge korrespondieren
einander wechselseitig welche dinge aber
ungleich sind erkennen wir nur durch ein
vergleich mit gleichen ding und nicht
umgekehrt usw
ja wie sieht jetzt das geheimnis der war
heiztechnik aus wer von ihnen kann das
noch mal neu formulieren oder
rekonstruieren
was müssen also im hinterkopf haben wenn
wir jetzt uns zusammengesetzt dinge
betrachten
worauf sie achten was muss unser ziel
sein
ist eigentlich ganz einfach
sagt er in der dritten zeile
die hand und noch davor eben als zweite
zeile ich habe ich gesagt das höchste
absolute dass das immer das höchste
absolute ist die frage ist das nicht
begrifflicher widerspruch ist das
absolut nicht als solche schon das
höchste oder das jetzt absolut heißt ja
das losgelöste letztendlich soll wäre
absolviere ablösen absolutes ist das
partizip das abgelöste das unabhängige
irgendwie das feststehende das was nicht
mehr in relationen bedingt ist also wir
sollten immer auf das im höchsten grade
absolute achten also immer weiter fragen
gibt sich noch etwas absolutes ist
eigentlich eigentlich widersprüchlich zu
sagen etwas absolutes entweder es ist
losgelöst oder nicht aber hier sehen sie
wieder wenn er von einer relativität des
absoluten spricht hat er immer
relationen im sinn
es geht also bei descartes und das ist
wieder ein hinweis auf diese karenz
theorie es geht immer darum dass sich
gewisse sätze in verhältnissen befinden
und wir sollen die verhältnisses zu
überblicken dass wir immer weiter
aufsteigen
erst sie hier
als ich glaube auch nicht dass es ein
unter logische theorie ist ja wie hegel
jetzt hat das absolute auch eine
substanz das absolut sondern es geht um
relationen
es geht um logische gefüge und
unabhängigkeit gefüge und das im
höchsten grade absolute ist ihm ein
axiom ein logischer grundsatz der uns
besonders einleuchtet der sich als
ausgezeichnet erweist weil alles andere
auf ihn mittelbar zurückgeführt werden
kann wenn sie diese serie jetzt sich
überlegen es gibt ab
leistungsverhältnisse wir reduzieren
oder analysieren sehr komplexe
sachverhalte nimmer basare und merken
irgendwann hoppla hier hört auf dieser
satz ist so einleuchtend den kann ich
also die man kann sich das fragen also
hier jetzt sicherlich nicht aber wenn
sie mal sich zum beispiel die
meditationen also die die die medikation
von descartes anschauen könnte man zur
auffassung kommen es gibt so ein
höchsten absoluten satz nämlich dieses
komitee ja diese selbstgewissheit da
sagt klika dann auch alles was uns in
dieser weise einleuchtet wie die
tatsache dass ich gerade hier bin
existiere das ich denke dass ich zweifel
das muss man sacken meditation
das ist jetzt nicht so meteorologisch
ausgearbeitet wir können vielleicht ich
schicke ihnen vielleicht noch mal dieser
stelle auch noch mal nach als
nachbereitung der heutigen sitzung das
einmal diese stelle szene sagte wirklich
alles was uns so eingeleuchtet wie
unsere selbstgewissheit das muss was
also wenn man die meditation liest
könnte man davon könnte man glauben dass
das so dieser dieser absoluten absolute
ist aber hier sicherlich nicht
ja ja also bei de cartier wichtig beide
karten meditation gibt es ja noch das
ein gottesbeweis das ist zu sein könnte
man das könnte man sich das so
vorstellen wie dieses platonische
dreieck das eben dann die idee des guten
noch drüber ist weil die karte
gottesbeweis die soziologisch
gottesbeweis und weil gott ihm all
gültig an mächtig ist muss eben müssen
die verhältnisse stimmen sondern muss
die korrespondenz gegeben sein gott
garantiert diese korrespondenz ja dass
wir uns nicht täuschen können diesen
klaren evidenzen das ist dann wieder ein
platonische modell
man kann die karte zu lesen dass es so
eine art grundsatz philosophie ist wie
sie fichte später gemacht hat aber das
auch nur mit einschränkungen also bei
einfach bei descartes das setting ein
anderes ist die card braucht in seinen
meditationen jedenfalls noch den begriff
gottes um die erkenntnis sichern zu
können und das ist bei fichte anders
fichte hat auch an gottesbegriff aber
der ist lang nicht so offensichtlich wie
bei descartes und die cis tatsache hat
fichte auch dann den vorwurf des
atheismus eingebracht es gibt den
sogenannten atheismus streit so um 1800
und da ist eben gerade das von
theologischer aber auch
wissenschaftlicher seite damals
vorgeworfen worden dass er doch
eigentlich mit seinem ich als höchsten
prinzip
gott erschafft so das ist diese
atheismus treiben da sehen sie schon am
setting je nachdem wie man es fügt
ergeben sich probleme also ich würde die
karte jetzt nicht als im technischen
sinne lesen und auch nicht im
platonischen sondern einfach im
logischen sinne
es geht darum dass die aktionen finden
die sich nicht mehr weiter auf andere
zurückführen lassen und von denen
ausgehend das ganze rekonstruieren
bitte
[Musik]
relativ 10
wichtig also ja also haben wichtigen
punkt angesprochen es geht um ordnung
wir brauchen ordner in unserem denken
und es gibt verschiedene geraden grades
gibt serien es gibt verhältnisse und wir
müssen eben versuchen alles in seinen
relation zu betrachten und auf einem
auch die priorität von manchen
sachverhalten gegenüber anderen
sachverhalten zu erkennen wäre
vielleicht noch einen punkt dazu dann
gehen wir weiter her
ach so ja also ich glaube letztendlich
ihm geht es um den gesamten zusammenhang
also er ist
ich würde schon sagen dass es so ein
auto ließ muss es muss also das ganze
spielt eine rolle
es geht um die verhältnisse des ganzen
in den teilen und wir müssen immer
weiter fragen wenn wir teilbereich
erkannt haben die in den größeren
kontext zusammen immer mehr versuchen
alles miteinander korrekt zu machen
und wenn wir es ja würde so würde ich
die karte lesen in diesem
rationalistischen idealen ja naja also
ließ ich denke so so wird die karts
plausibel ist doch ein sehr sehr starker
konkurrenz theoretiker und die frage
stellt sich immer immer wieder wie
bekommen wir die korrespondenz dann
trotz aller correns dass wir eine
spannende frage von der hausarbeit
also das kann ich jetzt schon mal sagen
zu fragen wie kommen wir aus dieser
großen kohärenz hinzu korrespondenz sie
versuchte das zu leisten
jetzt lese ich nochmal hier einst vor
nummer zwei zitate noch mal kurz und
ärger über zum nächsten denke es muss
zweitens darauf hingewiesen werden dass
es nur wenige rein und einfache naturen
gibt die man zuerst und für sich nicht
abhängig von irgendwelchen anderen
sondern intuitiv erkennen also da haben
wir es gibt nicht nur dass das eine
absolute sondern wenige rein und einfach
naturen achten sie auf den begriff der
natur das ist wieder anzeigen dafür dass
die karts jetzt hier die kohärenz mit
der korrespondenz in zitieren lassen
möchte
die natur ist ja die sache wie sie
wirklich ist wenn er von der reinen
natur spricht ist die rede so als ob er
sich den tatsächlichen schon befindet
sei es in den experimenten selbst oder
kraft eines gewissen uns eingepflanzten
lichts
schauen sie mal hier müsste jetzt hier
die lateinische entsprechung sich
anschauen wie hole ich nächstes mal ich
habe es jetzt gerade nicht vor sie
können auch in den lateinischen text
schauen wie es sagt er denn das
eingepflanzte licht lux irgendwas
was ist denn dieses eingepflanzt
vielleicht hat der eine oder die andere
der text grad vor sich das wäre
interessant ob eingepflanzt auch im
lateinischen heimischen original so
steht weil auffällig finde ich jetzt
hier schon dass hier eine metapher
verwendet wird die aus der natur bezogen
wurde eingepflanzt kann man sich
überlegen ob das jetzt in der deutschen
übersetzung nur eine metapher des
lateinischen ist oder ob eingepflanzt
auch im lateinischen so dasteht das
müssen wir jetzt nicht können sie mal
für sich überlegen wenn es im
lateinischen im original und müssen
immer das original uns zugrunde legen
auch schon eine metapher ist
eingepflanzt in diesem sinne
dann deutet das doch darauf hin dass
descartes hier das denken selbst als als
letztendlich immer schon qua natürlich
im licht als mit der wirklichkeit sie
eine übereinstimmung befinden denkt aber
der situation also eine kleine wertung
wir war wie wir sagen der sie sorgfältig
zu beobachten sind
sie sind es nämlich die wir jeder serie
die im höchsten grade einfach die wir in
jeder sähe die im höchsten grade einfach
einen an alle anderen aber lassen sich
nur erfassen indem sie aus den einfachen
naturen reduziert werden und zwar
entweder unmittelbar oder zunächst
folgend oder nur durch zwei drei oder
mehrere verschiedene schlüssel deren
zahl ebenfalls festgehalten werden muss
damit wir erkennen ob sie von der ersten
und in höchst und gerade einfachen
proposition mehr oder weniger stufen
weit entfernt sind das ist wieder dieses
relativ nationalistische verständnis es
geht immer um die relation was ist
absoluter das ist dieses diese gerade
weise vom absoluten gemessen an diesem
satz ist diese position absoluter und
wenn ich dann aber nochmal sie weiter
reduziere auf was allgemeine rest ist
sie nochmal absoluter usw
einen solchen kontext der folgerung dass
jetzt auch wichtig kontext der folgerung
das thema politisch geht um die das
gesamte
es geht um eine corinths solchen kontext
erfahrung gibt es überall dort wo jenes
sehen der fraglichen dinge ihre wurzel
habe auf die jede frage zurückzuführen
ist damit sie durch eine sichere methode
einer prüfung unterzogen werden kann
es ist aber weder leicht sie allesamt
durchzugehen noch ist es darum zu tun
sie im gedächtnis zu behalten sondern
darum sie mit dem schaf sind der
geisteskraft als unterschreiben
deshalb gilt es noch etwas zu fragen das
die geistes kräfte so bildet das sie
immer sofort bemerken wenn es nötig ist
wie ich erfahren konnte ist dazu nichts
geeigneter als ich an zu gewöhnen auch
über das geringste dessen was wir
bereits vorher erfasst haben mit einer
gewissen findigkeit nachzudenken
also es geht letztendlich auch um eine
denk pädagogik eine denkschule ja eine
denk methode ist einfach hilfreich ist
es in regeln die uns descartes an die
hand gibt die wahrheit der wahrheit auf
der spur zu bleiben
das eigentlich ein ratgeber es ist
nichts anderes als ein ratgeber aus dem
aus der frühen neuzeit ratgeber aus dem
17 jahrhundert
ja und jetzt noch zum schluss drittens
es muss schließlich drittens darauf
hingewiesen werden dass wir unsere
studie nicht mit der untersuchung
schwieriger dinge anfangen dürfen bevor
wir uns an irgendwelche bestimmte fragen
heranmachen ist es stattdessen
angebracht zuerst ohne irgend eine
vorauswahl von selbst auftretende
wahrheiten zu sammeln und erst dann
allmählich zu sehen ob sich aus ihnen
irgendwelche anderen reduzieren lassen
und aus diesen wiederum andere usw erst
dann wenn das getan ist sollte man
aufmerksam über die herausgefunden
wahrheiten nachdenken das heißt
sorgfältig darüber weshalb wir einen
zuerst angetroffen haben die einst erst
angetroffen haben und weshalb uns das
leichte gefallen ist als bei den anderen
und welche es eigentlich sind dann erst
werden wir auch beurteilen können auf
welche wir uns eigentlich zuerst stützen
sollten um andere herauszufinden
wenn wir irgend eine bestimmte frage in
angriff nehmen also ich glaube das geht
auch aus dem bereits davor gesagten
hervor
also immer einfach anfangen methodisch
geschickt und dann hier reduzieren
sie produzieren heißt logisch ableiten
logisch vom allgemeinen vom absoluten
zum relativen herabsteigen
also es geht um eine ganz ganz
methodisch gelenkte reflexion und kann
auch seine kritik unsere denkt
operationen und die offene frage ich
möchte noch mal sagen am ende ist die
wie wir trotz aller denkt vorrichtungen
denkt ordnungen denkt methoden am ende
nicht nur im denken selbst bleiben
sondern eben auch den schritt vom denken
zur wirklichkeit bewältigen können das
ist die spannende frage wie kommt die
karts vom denken zur wirklichkeit
das ist die frage ja weil kohärenz wie
wir gesagt haben noch nicht
korrespondenz verfügt aber erscheint das
in die frau zu setzen und ich habe hier
so ein paar anhaltspunkte glaubt
erkennen in dem von natur die rede ist
von licht von natürlich eingepflanzten
nicht an solchen naturalistischen
metaphern die scheine nahe zu legen dass
descartes das denken doch auf einen noch
näher zu erklärende weise mit der
tatsächlichen welt in einer verbindung
steht das wäre eine spannende frage von
heraus
so jetzt haben wir hier haben sie noch
fragen zu descartes ich glaube wir haben
hier jetzt verschiedene aspekte
angerissen also immer die vor dem
hintergrund der frage korrespondenz
tiere oder kohärenz theorie das sehen
mit diesen zwei begriffen als kategorien
kann man jede klassische war ziemlich
interessant bestimmen weil es häufig so
ist dass es nicht nur das ein oder
andere ist als entweder war entweder
korrespondenz theorie oder konkurrenz
theorie und dass es häufig
verschränkungen von beiden sind ja das
haben wir schon bei platon gesehen
klassischen sinne das ist eine
verschränkung ist und wir sehen auch
wieder bei descartes das hier
verschränkung stattfinden die jetzt im
gegensatz zu platon er an der
ansetzen und nicht an die korrespondenz
das müsste man noch genauer bestimmen
aber das ist jedenfalls eine
interessante frage auch für eine
hausarbeit
so jetzt in der noch verbleibenden zeit
gehen wir über gottfried wilhelm leibniz
und er hat eine schrift verfasst zum
thema neue abhandlung über den
menschlichen verstand und auch da habe
ich mal wieder leitfragen die ich zuerst
hier angeben möchte also wir haben hier
die erste welche arten von wahrheit
unterscheidet leibnitz weil er das
ziemlich systematisch macht und dann
wieder unsere klassische frage vertrete
eine kohärenz oder eine korrespondenz
theorie der wahrheit und noch eine habe
ich die wir natürlich auch immer wieder
im hinterkopf behalten sollten
wie verhält sich sein wahrheit' begriff
zu den bislang diskutierten spannend ist
jetzt hier vor allem descartes weil
leibnitz ja in unmittelbarer nähe zu der
tat seine theorie entwickelt hat weil er
auch ganz traditionell im allgemeinen
sinne als ein rationalist bezeichnet
werden kann gibt es da unterschiede
sie werden sehen dass auch diese
einfachsten ideen diese aktion mit bei
leibnitz eine große rolle spielen
wir müssen schauen wie wir das dann aber
noch genauer erfasst
und jetzt haben sie hier wieder
sicherlich gesehen es handelt sich hier
um einen dialog
also wir haben immer den film den muss
man noch ergänzen alle tees das ist der
weiß jemand was das heißt viel alle tees
realität ist wie man das auch immer
ausspricht ist ein griechischer name der
eine bedeutung hat wie alle griechischen
namen
janni fast also es ist es ist es also
das viel ist die eine silbe die
bedeutung tragend ist will und dann noch
alle tees genau wahrheit' vollen genauer
lädt er die wahrheit viel ihrer
philosophie sie kennen es ist die liebe
ist also der wahrheitsliebe dann haben
wir auch noch immer als nächstes haben
wir dann den theophilus ist dann der
gottlieb der gottlieb und der wahrheit
vor
und sie können daran schon ersehen dass
jeder dieser protagonisten dieser
dialogpartner natürlich eine gewisse
nähe hat also der finalität es wird ihr
der philosophie zu gerechnet werde
traditionellen philosophie und der
theophilus ihr vielleicht der theologie
der theologischen debatten könnte man
jetzt annehmen wir müssen schauen ob das
stimmt ich gehe mal wieder vor all die
finalität sagt viele jahrhunderte hat
man schon gefragt fast die wahrheit ist
die unsrigen glauben dass es die
verbindung oder trennung der zeichen je
nach der übereinstimmung oder nicht
übereinstimmung der dinge untereinander
untereinander ist unter der verbindung
oder trennung der zeichen muss
verstanden werden was man sonst einen
satz der urteil nennt also was für eine
wahrheits theorie ist jetzt hier
angesprochen klar ja
genau korrespondenz als hier der hamas
übereinstimmung einstimmung nicht
übereinstimmung der dinge untereinander
ist ein bisschen unklar formuliert weil
es geht ja gut je nach also ist die
übereinstimmung ist jetzt nicht das
entscheidende sondern die trennung
derzeit je nach also die die zeichen
richten sich nach den verhältnissen der
dinge untereinander nicht ganz da
zeichnen haben sie eine idee ja
ja also zeit also sprache zeichensysteme
aber sie haben einen berechtigten
einwand schon gemacht weil der
theophilus der sagt jetzt auch hier das
ist ja nicht ganz genau was du jetzt da
uns erzählt der theophilos sagt jetzt
hier aber ein bei wort macht noch keinen
satz zb der weise menschen gleich dabei
eine verbindung zweier ausdrücke
stattfinden also der theorie dass
kritisiert jetzt die definition von dem
finalität findet doch auch eine
verbindung zweier ausdruck stadt also
hier
er sagt die verbindung oder trennung der
zeichen in übereinstimmung mit der
wirklichkeit jetzt sagt er
teofilo sie aber die verbindungen
übereinstimmung die verbindung
verzeichnen die machen noch keinen satz
ich kann sagen der weise menschen
der weiße mensch und zwar das führte zu
diesem problem wird sie sagen dass der
term der weise mensch dass das eine
position ist
würden sie sagen dass der weise mensch
hier erste zeile ist das eine position
das würden sie sagen also nach unserem
verständnis der proposition wie es in
den ersten sitzung erläutert hatte